الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير زيلنسكي اعلن
بدا التجهيز لعقد قمه سلام دوليه حول
الازمه الاوكرانيه في سويسرا من دون تحديد
جدول زمني بشان الموعد المحتمل لعقدها
زيلنسكي اعرب ايضا عن عدم ترحيبه بمشاركه
روسيا في قمه
السلام ممتن لسياده الرئيسه وفريقها بعد
موافقتها بداء فرقنا التحضير لقمه السلام
الدوليه في سويسرا على مستوى القاده
نحن منفتحون على مشاركه كل دول العالم
التي تحترم سيادتنا ووحده اراضينا لذلك
يمكنكم استخلاص استنتاجات بشان من
سندعو الرئيس الاوكراني تحدث لاول مره عن
خطه السلام التي تطرحها كيف خلال قمه
مجموعه العش في نوفمبر تشرين الثانيه
الماضي والتي تضمنت الدعوه الى استعاده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانسحاب الوات الروسيه
ووقف الاعمال العدائيه واطلاق سراح جميع
السجناء
والمحتجزين هذا وتدخل الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا عامها الثالث في فبراير المقبل
في ظل تكثيف موسكو لضربات الجويه على
اوكرانيا في الاسابيع
الاخيره